[Música]
não é nossa intenção é que eles não
sabem se ela sumiu a falar ea um tento
solitário foi só uma delas se note uma
delas menina que a nossa fila o choque o
negócio enquanto surge outra coisa que
nós não estamos na nossa filha nossa
opinião uma frase que é e todos aqui uma
vez na vida não tem tempo ruim
[Aplausos]
[Música]
deve ter um cachorro se resolve então é
melhor pra você e fala não merece mesmo
tempo a e uma hora só ser um perigo não
é assim mas também moral à menina e não
ligo que normalmente não é tão
importante que tem aí aparece na minha
cultura am como outras coisas igualmente
importante que eu gosto muito do ponto é
dando uns alguns conselhos e explicamos
um carinho que é isso que vai da
competição e isto vai em primeiro lugar
eu entrei na faculdade não num
contingente geral entrei no contingente
especial constituído alta competição
permitiu entrar com uma média mais baixa
é preciso ter no mesmo dia 14 nos exames
de 2014 mas não específicas
outra coisa muito importante que sem
isso eu não conseguia ter feito curso os
chamados em o vitória que nos permite
escolher as turmas
sempre tive a maior facilidade e tem
agora de ser aprovado ensina essa ajuda
que me deram foi que realmente não
conseguia ter feito passar gel as provas
já estavam feitas e simplesmente escolhi
as turmas onde mandava mais gente para
conseguir treinar a partir do quarto
ministro num caminho mais difícil porque
implica as aulas práticas manhã em nosso
time principal na canon agência de manhã
temos sempre treino de água em que
muitas vezes em que implica tripulações
ou seja não não dependemos só de nós e
temos outras pessoas que estão à nossa
espera que pena em nós
eu tenho é esse é um caminho mais
recente foi aprovado nã o está no
estatuto de atletas prudente apesar da
universidade de coimbra através do
gabinete de desporto da ou sejá uti
desde o ano passado
este estudo é um caminho diferente os da
alta competição porque porque primeiro
não é difícil até falar da competição
basta fazer desporto universitário o que
é uma grande
uma hora mais lhe permite é muito mais
gente praticar atividade física no campo
algo que os 30 atletas de alta
competição não é por mim portanto
permite-nos nem que seja para manter a
nossa saúde para termos um homem em
frente ajudando nisso permite facilidade
de exames principalmente 393 fatos
normal curso especial permite consegue
esta é a construção do horário por mim
anos 12 anos um estatuto em que
conseguimos construir nosso próprio pai
para atender os mais fácil mentores aos
treinos
a exemplo de outros países o meu
treinador foi um blog durante muito
tempo na polônia eu saía realizar a
troca por causa de lesão e na polônia
municipal está em turmas que são só
atletas ou seja está em alguns têm uma
pausa para ir treinar e voltam a ter
aulas ou seja não é um treino
condicionado pelas aulas mas são as
aulas ficam condicionadas pelo trânsito
em primeiro lugar está o trem ea pressão
enquanto atleta e depois vêm as aulas e
é todo adaptado em função dos treinos em
países como itália república checa e
outros não é universidade mas na escola
da polícia não funciona como em portugal
basicamente seus fazem o curso que está
em the office mas não é mais de um ano
eu acabo se quase uma formação e depois
disso o trabalho deles o emprego deus
não é simplícia para além de algumas
dogmas situações simbólicas entende está
presente como é óbvio o trabalho de 100
atletas e está em tudo o que recebe um
salário para treinar
para allen as fora o a bolsa do comité
olímpico que minha o segundo clube tanto
é garante de uma carreira que é uma
coisa muito importante e quem pratica
desporto a atenção só que em portugal
ninguém vive do desporto com o resto da
vida
daí eu tenho que ser titular
e aqui isso permite ter uma carreira
gloriosa e presença de carga simples e
sem pensarem que quando acabar a
carreira de lewis não vão ter dinheiro
mais para viver em outra frase que há um
caminho a minha máxima é quanto mais
tempo temos - fazemos e o restante se
fazer uma pausa nos estudos ou
praticamente uma pausa e tua antônio
isto que eu tenho muito mais tempo para
fazer tudo quero mas simplesmente não
faço porque posso fazer amanhã
e daqui é um caminho que eu disse no
início do primeiro tempo
eu agora tenho tempo só que eu não quero
fazer não quero assim tanto fazer outras
coisas
tanto em alguns concelhos que durante os
dois anos é coisa mais importante que
fazer para ter sucesso foi rentabilizado
o tempo eu acabava não só em saber que
entraria na cota tóquio teve uma série
de maior que o tempo que tinha até o
time pode estudar eu sabia que tenha
obrigatoriamente titular porque não ia
ter tempo mais histórias para ver o que
não o que não consegui ver daqui a um
tempo não entrar em pânico
os três é uma realidade nesta fila e aí
podemos anos de vida e é muito crível
frente mas é importante não entrar em
pânico e para não entrar em pânico é
importante definir metas e definir
pequenos objetivos a curto prazo porque
treinou hoje com a placa já repete mas
como pagamento e fica em agosto seu
treino hoje com o objectivo de em agosto
por aí porque com o objetivo que eu
tenho é de niterói
até lá está indo e encontrando objetivos
a curto prazo prime tem por missão
manter a motivação e permitam conseguir
manter um foco no que eu quero mas
lembrem sempre que eu quero porque eu
estou a fazer esse sacrifício
por último é importante organizar o
nosso dia a nossa semana em portanto
temos um mapa na nossa cabeça o que
temos que fazer aqui o que temos que
fazer ali o que precisamos é basicamente
construindo um caminho e organizar tudo
da melhor maneira para não nos perdermos
não
eu já falei com ele sobre isso que o
sacrifício mas esta questão do que é o
sacrifício
há pouco tempo eu fiz uma reportagem e
pronto para o mixto e eu acho que nunca
tinha pensado nisto que todos os dias
jogo na minha vida destes anos todos de
conciliar as duas coisas fiz muito
sacrifício ou via já estava tão cansada
de ficar na história até às duas da
manhã no dia anterior que não apreciam
antônio para treinar e ainda por cima
estava a chuva estava frio tal evento
eu não criei mas gilvan time fui e
depois j pergunta que quando é que nós
pensamos nisso que eu acho que é aquela
que ele quase nunca ou quando podemos só
quando ganhamos é quando nós lembramos
assim a maioria das vezes quando
queremos que esse canal devia ter feito
mais um carinho por ele e sei que é
difícil todos eu posso contar uma
história em 2015 eu tentei complementou
primeira vez de capa 4 e não conseguimos
por 18 milésimos de segundos
eu não sabia o que era um trote
milésimos de segundo até esse dia em que
foi o tempo me deixou fora dos jogos
olímpicos filho foi costumo ecológico
não começar a nova época motivada mas
fiz o que é difícil treinar mais uma
época uma época vai tentar uma pra mim
novamente em maio
isso já perguntar valeu a pena valeu
tudo que é mãe eu conseguir o apuramento
olímpico e que fizemos nos primeiros
jogos olímpicos
espero que nos une é porque agora vai
ver um novo parlamento e é por aí
acho que por menos pois lançou durante
as coisas mas eu sei que não é popular
por 18 milésimos de segundo
achei que eu puder pelo menos 18
milésimos de segundo mas não sei quando
é que foi nós temos tendência a droga
algumas coisas e esquece segundos de
outras tanto falamos apenas foi a maior
experiência foi a melhor experiência da
minha vida quero muito tinha quero muito
voltar em acho que é o sonho de qualquer
atleta que pratica a modalidade olímpica
estará presente no maior no maior evento
desportivo do mundo e por ele e eu fiz
uma tatuagem acho que é esse diz ao pai
a única console como fazer na minha vida
é se for jogos e eu continuo a não
aceitar mas enquanto que o médio tenha
o que foi proibida no desporto permite
que os adquiriram uma série de valores é
que eu já falei alguns que nos permitam
lidar com nossa linha de maneira
diferente tanque jackman por um toque
com duas ou três vitórias nervosa eu não
porque não saí já é tão normal teve
situações de stress a minha vida uns 3
diariamente que eu fiz muito mais do que
uma história aqui e falar pra vocês
sobre a minha experiência sobre o que é
como é que eu conseguir fazer isto que
não há segredos na verdade é um cara de
vocês quererem que que está nervosa já é
uma coisa que acho que já está em nato
em mim quando todos estes valores subiu
11 carinho não estamos no tempo que é
sobre o que eu tô aqui falar e tirando
muito em toda a europa que eu acho que é
muito importante é nós na canoagem
permitem conhecer gente muito país
conhecer culturas diferentes consegue
religiosos em frente e vencer esforços e
frios que as pessoas têm que fazer
consoante o país ainda estão por exemplo
pessoas que vivem na dinamarca em que
neva no inverno tem de fazer história de
notícias do do mundo estarem fora de
causa imenso tempo felizmente nós não
precisamos muito disso porque em
portugal da parte mais bonita
isso permite um carinho tem um horizonte
mais aberto eo melhor com as coisas do
dia a dia de uma regra de frente tanto
por último quero sua história também a
soja que queria poder e realmente o que
define se nós temos ou não temos tempo
para fazer o que o que queremos é nossa
vontade tanto nova e convém eu que estou
agora disse ney que fazer canoagem
vantagem poderia ter tido melhor
resultado só podia ter tido uma melhor
média no curso
provavelmente sim mas não foi isso que
eu queria fazer nenhum e não é o que eu
propus a fazer foi a de fazer um ensina
o dólar ensina e fazer canoagem alta
competição e mesmo assim temos um toque
também foi entregue um puzzle querer
aprender tanto que se eu conseguir você
também consegue nos seus diferentes
obrigado
[Aplausos]